hello everyone welcome to another hd
tutorial in this one i'll be showing you
how to run a program in compatibility
mode if you're having issues with it in
windows vista
first of all
if you you're using windows xp
and or windows vista and using a program
that was actually built for the other
operating system say i was having
problems with notepad
uh you want to first of all put that
icon on your desktop
once this icon is on my desktop i'm
going to right click it and hit
properties which will bring up a window
as you can see here what i'm going to
click is the compatibility tab it's just
intuitive of course
and it'll say do you want to run the
program in compatibility mode and i'm
just going to
if you are if this program will allow
you to this box won't be grayed out and
you can actually check that box and
select from the list which one you want
to run in compatibility mode for
so
obviously notepad does not have a
compatibility mode but say
i was having problems with microsoft
word uh maybe the microsoft works word
processor i don't actually have to open
it my bad
i'll click in word drag an icon to the
desktop of it and say yes of course i
want to drag it to the desktop uic
so
from here i'm going to right click it
and properties just to see if i can
actually work it in compatibility mode
and there are no compatibility modes for
if you actually are having a problem
with a program and you need to try to
attempt to run it in
compatibility mode for an older
operating system this is completely fine
it will it might look a little bit
different there might be some slightly
different
um uh user interface changes there might
be a little different it might be just
an older version or it might just have a
different look to it
so all in all uh that is a quick way to
get your programs to work in
compatibility mode uh here we go this
you just check this box
and you'll get a little drop down of all
these older operating systems say i want
to pick 95
i would just click on it and hit apply
and it would always run in compatibility
mode you can also run it in a window
such as a 640 640x480 window you can
change to run to disable visual themes
to say have it run faster
certain things like this run as an
administrator
so that's how you run a program in
compatibility mode um thanks for
watching guys hope this helps
and for more tutorials just subscribe
and if you have any ideas for a uh hd
tutorial just send me a personal message
thanks for watching peace